hey guys it is Friday and we're here to
talk to you about three of the biggest
things that happened in gaming this week
and tell you our thoughts on them to
share your thoughts in that comment
section below but for now let's get into
it as the unstoppable flow of time keeps
hurtling us towards the end of the year
and to the grave it means it's almost
time for getting with EU nominations and
the game awards yes the game Ward's
which whether you love them or hate them
are always entertaining but there's one
particular really interesting nominee
that's up for the grand prize this yet
and that's Clara nerds battlegrounds the
reason you probably already know that
it's an interesting nominee if the game
isn't officially out yet yeah it really
really access it is still in early
access it's due out soon it's you're out
on Xbox one on December 12th but even
then it's still coming to the game
preview program so it's still not a full
release what's supposed to have its 1.0
PC release the time in December but that
doesn't take away from the main fact
that it's an early access game and it's
actually got three nominations within
the game awards categories when Brendan
green player unknown himself was asked
about it he said he didn't know if they
deserved that a would and he doesn't
really want to win it
he cited games like Zelda breath of the
wild and horizon as absolute
masterpieces and he reckoned they should
win the game of the year would and not
battle grams as much as he said it would
be great for the team he reckons that
may be good not bad just let's give
everybody a little bit of a preview of
game of the year what's on your list for
this year man there's so many great
games as Brendan Green said horizon the
right game Zelda awesome game I
personally really love persona 5
hell-blade oh baby pop head
Mario rabbits Kingdom battle super mario
Watusi
strife pack met labyrinth it's all there
it's gonna be great well let us know
what's on your game of the year list
down in that comment section and let's
do our next story just no one lies on
the internet no one lies I must of
course you're the Russian Ministry for
defense ah yes they do lie on the
internet although I think accidentally
because it would be weird if they did
this on purpose
basically what they did was to wait out
proof that the US is working with Isis
yes some Cal Russia the US and Isis have
Pierre Donna GameSpot news story here we
are the reason this relates to gaming is
that the picture the image they showed
which they said was irrefutable proof
that the u.s. is working with Isis is
actually from a mobile game oh dear oh
dear
yes someone ran a Google reverse image
search and I guess she was up pretty
clear that it's just a screenshot yeah
the person who found it was researcher
in academic Eliot Higgins who wrote up
his findings on the online myth-busting
site Belling cat yeah as you can imagine
the photos
been deleted from the Twitter account
but not before we got our hands on it
and so did a bunch of other people so uh
let's just enjoy this extremely
ludicrously strange story no one were
throwing all that mobile game features
microtransactions what a perfect segue
into the story of the week EA star wars
loot crate's microtransactions you would
have seen those words through I think
almost every news episode we've made
this week because it is the biggest
thing that's happening in gaming right
now is a whole lot of controversy over
not just loot crate's in background but
loot crate's across the board how
governments are regulating them should
they regulate them should they be
classed as gambling should they thought
the class is gambling but let's do a
really quick recap so we've revealed
when reviews were starting to come out
about Star Wars Battlefront 2 that the
time to unlock certain characters like
Darth Vader Luke Skywalker basically all
the characters you'd want to play as was
tied to about 40 hours of game time
because you had yeah each and you had to
earn I think was about 60,000 credits or
something to pay for one character yeah
you responded they reduced the cost down
to 15,000 then people found that at the
end of the single-player campaign when
you used to be awarded 20,000 credits
you are now being awarded 5,000 credits
and EA is justification for that was
because at the end of the campaign they
wanted you to buy item versio the
protagonist of the single-player
campaign yeah for for playing
multiplayer so that's half of the
problem the other half of the problem is
the loot crate yes where you get stock
hearts and the problem and the reason
that we haven't heard all this
controversy with the game like overwatch
and we are hearing it now is there are
loads all of its skill based things
cropping up in those loot crate's a big
one that came up in the last couple of
days that appeared on reddit is
something
actually increases your ability to
auto-aim which is really crazy I haven't
seen that yeah there's obviously there's
star cards that increase things like
your stealth you won't appear on mini
maps and none of these are tied to
progression all of these are tied to
random loot drops in loot crate and so
it started it's sort of raising
obviously the very the very obvious
question of is this game pay2win and on
the surface it absolutely looks like it
but I would go so far as to say stop
hater wins pay for the chance to win
yeah
because none of these are guaranteed
drops you're not buying a crate that is
guaranteed gonna guarantee you you're
gonna get this perfect stealth mod it's
just giving you the chance to maybe get
it well and that's what perfectly leads
into what belgium is investigating right
now is whether these programs whether
these systems do classify as gambling
specifically they don't know what you're
getting yes specifically they're looking
at overwatch and battlefront too as to
whether or not they do constitute
gambling obviously the ESRB also looked
into that recently and they ruled that
it's not gambling because no matter what
you do you're going to get content that
is usable in a game you're not actually
losing anything when you're getting you
may not get what you want but you're not
losing anything like you can't open a
crate and get nothing that may have been
the ESRB ruling but it's certainly not
what a lot of you seem to be saying
given I knew your ass once on game saw
it and your response on reddit reddit
reddit currently um has a petition going
to oxy ESRB to basically revisit their
ruling as of the time of shooting it has
over 50,000 signatures and I think the
point of all of this controversy I think
the main thing we can drill down into is
the very top post on all of games for
the last week which is vote with your
wallet
absolution isn't something that you're
happy with if this isn't a system you
want to support then don't pick up the
game if it's something that you don't
mind if it's something it doesn't affect
your experience a battlefront - or any
other game then that's your choice as
well of course as soon as we finish
recording this story EA decides to
remove all micro transactions from Star
Wars Battlefront - that's right no more
micro transactions at all in battlefront
- the crystal shop has been completely
removed with EA and dice pledging not to
return it until they've found the right
balance for
microtransactions what form that's going
to take they're asking for your input on
and they are saying that Star Wars
Battlefront 2 is a game that they want
input and thoughts and they want it to
be around for a long time so keep giving
them your feedback on this one I think
that's everything we have for you today
we will see you guys in about two days
for extra life that's right if you are
watching on gamespot comm we've been
going for five hours at this point the
extra life streams 72 hours of video
games non-stop for the kids there's 36
hours in the u.s. office thing well that
was in the UK office rounding it out is
24 hours with Jess and I here in
Australia we'll have special guests just
Eddie but you can tune in right now so
go to twitch.tv pour / games what go
donate if you can do it we are
supporting children's charity this year
and your money will go to a really good
cause but in the meantime thank you so
much for joining us and have a great
rest of weekend we'll see you guys bye
it's the end of the working week which
means one thing and one thing only it's
time for us to tell you about three of
the biggest stories of the week and what
we think about them thank you for tuning
in this is the game spot news front
around up that is so annoying we will we
will not be doing that again it's a well
it's a well-known fact that Clark I know
know what I'm we're throwing all that
mobile game features microtransactions
[Laughter]